[Music]
America
America
I'm beginning to see why your wife left
here
[Music]
what cares about is animals and food is
that true Francis yep we're gonna go for
pizza tonight
we're going to sleep tonight
we're playing each other on Battleship
and Francis is not the Performing what's
the plan for the first meal in New York
I'm gonna get pizza slices you've got a
plan for the of course I've got a plan
please let us know and we find you a
different seasons
you know what you actually look very
Latino there
oh I never realized you have any earring
there oh yeah I was just looking
at the job
oh yeah
[Music]
so here we are we're in New York it's
exciting time it's Constantine's gone in
there just work out how much money you
can save on brand so here it is this is
uh downtown Manhattan we're on left by
8th Street we're between Lafayette and
spring you know we're near one of the
greatest Pizza takeaway joints literally
around the corner so we'll pick this up
later later on Monday afternoon
a meat relapse mate a meat lapse yeah
but we we can't capture it on camera no
evidence
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
he's not a celebrity stop touching me
I've been here about two minutes Francis
has already dragged us to one of his
local haunts yeah this is owned by my
uncle Pablo yeah right he made a lot of
money exporting sugar back in the 80s
from Colombia but we're here in New York
it's going to be awesome we're going to
get some food and then we'll probably go
and catch a show at the Comedy Cellar
and go to bed are very very tired after
a long trip and then we start the fun
stuff tomorrow exactly and by fun we
mean no we're done we just means like
work really yeah can we go now okay
Anton look at that mate that is flossing
Marilyn Monroe English
just wear something weird and spread
your legs
for 10 minutes
[Music]
[Music]
we think that we know but we don't know
yeah all those all Americans from the
south are like this
I don't know what they're like yeah you
saw Hollywood movie about it yeah
foreign
[Music]
Chicken in there we went to a shitty
Mexican place right you could have told
us this before there's a place I can
take that's actually nice no yeah go to
an average Mexican place yeah but it was
the ambience when we were at dinner the
other night
dinner the other night in the morning
you're in London
afternoon in New York that is incredible
and we don't appreciate it
incredible
so what's happened is we were gonna go
to bed but then somebody said why don't
we get an ice cream what I did is I
looked up a place that is highly rated
to get an ice cream right and we get
here and there's a massive [ __ ] queue
yeah she's just over there at which
point Francis says oh this place is
famous poon boom wanted to take me here
but we couldn't come here because the
queue was too long
appreciating here now so I'm going to be
able to queue Bosch are we gonna go
yes
[Music]
but I will never do what she does to you
it's a shame all right so we waited in
the queue for about a zillion years
however was it not worth it
where have you got there Francis Heaven
mate I went very vanilla and by Vanilla
I mean vanilla and chocolate and he had
some kind of fruity number come on Peach
and a salty chocolate incredible cheese
now we're gonna eat this and we're
actually gonna go home and sleep and get
ready for the day tomorrow all right
good night
all right so good morning everyone day
two and it's France's happiest time of
the day come on let's get moving we've
got breakfast as you can see he's very
determined he's walking in his London
walk yeah and that's because it's
breakfast time
yes you never see them this happy on the
show Francis turn around
yeah you can all make me even happier if
we were sitting there having [ __ ]
breakfast and what are we doing today
we're trying to get all our cameras back
which we haven't got and microphones as
well so we've got to sort that out then
we're meeting up with Nathan Woodard for
dinner and preparing for interviews
tomorrow it's a bit of an admin day it's
been fun with Nathan tonight
so you can't find the eggshell no this
is why he needs me even when it comes to
food he can't find it they are
right we just crossed from there to
there that means we walk past it back
then in a city
that doesn't
after all this walking This brilliant
food place that Francis was taking us to
have breakfast
and we're in the Egg Shop uh it's uh
just near the Village in New York I've
been stopped twice for eating my food
which I'm fine about because we're
creating content you know in no way
angry it's a great place it's really
lovely it's got a great Vibe so I'm
doing we're not reviewing restaurants
serious shot there's the political
interviews we're having breakfast guys
bye I've got uh I can't remember it's
something to do with Korea cheese bacon
and egg
oh yeah
I'm happy
now we're gonna go and see if we can
actually get some cameras and
microphones that we need to record
interviews tomorrow yeah I mean that
would be good otherwise what we could do
is record them and then we could just
basically relate it back to you about
how great it was yeah well that wasn't
really good recording yeah it won't just
be telling them it'd be relaying yeah so
we'll be running around today and we'll
keep you updated
[Music]
thank you
yeah
so it's lunch time we are in apparently
the best pizza place in New York we
spent all morning running around because
we made the great decision to ship all
our equipment over here by ups and UPS
sucks our packaged with all our gear got
stuck and it's still in the UK while
we're here so we've been running around
trying to basically Source some
equipment we needed for some incredible
interviews over the next few days in New
York now we are here for some
well-deserved lunch here we are indeed
now this restaurant was recommended To
Us by a great guy and former guest
Winnie the Marshall Winston so in his
wrong words this is the best pizza place
in town I responded with the words
so we'll see if it's good great if not
then uh Winston it's your fault I don't
know if you'll see this but if he
doesn't then please make sure to tag him
on Twitter could I just have like a
house red or something like that could I
please have a small pizza half of it
which is Ruby Rosa Supreme the other
you think that's weird but yeah he does
I've got some kind of spicy Supreme it's
called the Supremo named after me it's
meatball you know pepperoni Gumtree
Winston it's not good this is uh some
kind of sausage and broccoli rub or
they've got broccoli rub in America is
incredible
what we've done right is we've gone for
pizza now I have been very good with my
diet I've got a personal trainer that
happened yeah it's winter Marshals for
recommending this it's not my fault it's
Winston but that pizza place was
incredible it was tonight we're gonna
meet top level bigger Nathan Woodard
which will be great we'll go have some
dinner with him yeah and then we've got
interviews starting tomorrow assuming we
can get our [ __ ] equipment so
yesterday we met up with one of our top
supporters called Nathan Woodard and is
legitimately the most interesting person
that I think any of us has ever met we
went out for a nice meal then we went to
a jazz bar and it was very interesting
conversation he also gave us some useful
advice that we were like really Keen to
ask him went to an incredible restaurant
as well had wonderful food the company
was excellent the food was incredible
service was great it was a perfect
evening and now we're off for our first
interview I'm doing an interview
yannickellick on his show and then we're
interviewing him in the afternoon yeah I
think we've also on Ryan Long's podcast
oh yeah that would be awesome as well
Jan's interviewing me about the book and
then we're interviewing him in the
afternoon my head is spinning slightly
both from the conversation and because
we stayed out quite late quite quite
late we meet midnight yeah but we're 40.
mate we're in our 40s now you know
that's quite late everybody when it hit
midnight went yeah time to wrap this up
yeah there was a Blog next to us in the
jazz bar who did nothing but basically
snug the ass off his date whilst wearing
age did you see him no I didn't no I
don't agree with that it's unnatural a
little bit of uh info for you TK Maxx in
America is called
yeah no it makes you think doesn't it
[Music]
so that was the wrong building basically
it was the wrong building and we were
told that and I was [ __ ] uncertain
terms
and we're back with Constantine kissing
his book again is an immigrant's love
letter to the West
anyway so we are at the epoch time
studio uh our brilliant friend Diana
Kelly is about to interview me about the
book then we're going to have some lunch
which Francis will be happy about and
then we will flip it around and we'll
interview yam so it's an awesome pack
day today so now you're seeing that
there's still a lot of strange things
going on back here playing with
electronics yeah so what you can see
here is Jan actually prepares for
interviews unlike us and now we're here
with Francis and Anton to do Ryan Long's
podcast yeah we're going to be on Ryan
Long's podcast former guest of the show
and all around a good egg so we're
looking forward to it we've got no idea
where we're [ __ ] going is it this one
we have glossifier and then I [ __ ]
don't yell as much
how to be a better life
orgasms for dummies man it's so much fun
thanks for having me
that was great man thanks for having us
on I actually was gonna have maybe the
Mumford and Sons guy because I watched
your interview
um
hungry
when are you not feeling hungry it's
true but particularly now feeling extra
obviously now even I'm feeling hungry so
we're gonna go and get some food but
also tonight we are going to The Comedy
Cellar we're gonna meet the people who
run it we've been in touch with them for
ages and also we're gonna see what may
turn out to be a very special comedy
show indeed looking forward to it so
we're about to go to the comedy show
we've got a very exciting performance
with Kevin Hart and Chris Rock
potentially we don't intentionally they
could be there but we're gonna go and
meet some friends here first uh get to
know a few people and we'll update you
after
foreign
[Music]
we went into the Comedy Cellar we saw
this guy here Coleman Hughes he was
there we got to meet some cool people
that we've been friends with for a long
time and then we saw a cracking comedy
show not least because Kevin Hart turned
up and we got to see Kevin Hart and this
morning we've just done an interview
with Coleman which was incredible how
many of you could describe the interview
with one word what would it be
fantastic
that's authenticity right there thank
you to our Anonymous supporter who let
us stay here and use this space we're a
big big fan of his you know so he is
every afternoon
I think there's a big divide in what the
media and news are saying or like when
Biden comes out and says a Thing versus
what everyone's actually feeling and I
think comedy slid right into that Gap
and fisted it so we have just
interviewed Mark Norman's absolutely
brilliant we had a great chat you are
gonna love this episode it's funny it's
informative it's it's a great episode
thank you for sweating and we're all
sweating and Mark is gonna issue a
formal complaint to our HR department
for the lack of uh open yes a very hard
my genitals are a stew
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so we are at a Korean barbecue place
start with the important stuff made why
are you wearing your sunglasses I guess
I am take them off I'm an international
Superstar what's up
[ __ ] he's got why is he wearing
sunglasses
we interviewed Mark Norman grilling
comedian and Coleman Hughes returned to
the show this morning as well we stayed
out until very late last night so we're
all tired we're gonna have some food go
back have a rest then we've got two more
interviews tomorrow we do indeed we're
not going to tell you yet to make some
good ones so we're at the Wu which is
probably my favorite name for a
restaurant ever
and uh you're gonna have another
meat-based relapse and we're gonna love
it I genuinely feel like this trip has
just been magical it's just so enjoyable
and like the definitely people that with
me and the different experiences that
we're having and the conversations I
love America I love America I'm British
always have been always cool people the
excitement that you get I don't know
they could take it yeah they could be
mine yeah
yeah pretty much pretty much either way
people die there's something about
America that is unique you just feel
that this is where this stuff happens
and what happens in the UK are just
ripples of like the explosions around
the and everything that happens here
this is classic beeping band that
everybody knows and love which is a
staple of Korea we've seen with the
fried egg on top it's Sublime and I like
a lot of places that you visit like your
wagamamas or anything else it never
feels like a dish it's just disparate
ingredients Belong Together whereas this
feels like a complete dish mixed
together into Sublime
it's nice
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
this is great I think it's the vanilla
here is incredible
[Music]
Impressions I heard Mark Norman was just
here I can still feel his hey hey buddy
one of the reasons we wanted to have you
on is obviously this situation with you
and a potential agent manager you were
about to get signed they said they
really liked you and then they were like
we can't work with you because you're a
White Guy what's happening now is
they're removing certain races from even
having the opportunity to compete you
know the pendulum will swing back and
I'm going the pendulum is broken out of
the [ __ ] clock and it's just like
slamming
I don't want to hear the pendulum
analogy
foreign